and by the way not to be too harsh you
know on the libertarian effect on the
conservative movement but a lot of the
reason why the libs have become so good
specifically over the last 60 years at
wielding the government in a way that it
was not very good actually at before you
saw you know you saw the beginnings of
Woodrow Wilson and FDR but you still had
a lot of conservative political power
within the government a lot of the
reason why we're not good at it anymore
is because the Libertarians convinced
the conservatives that wielding
political power per se is wrong and
immoral and by doing that we conceded
the entire political field and now the
libs run all of the institutions the
conservatives and Republicans being weak
has nothing to do with Libertarians they
decided that for themselves
they're the ones that went along with a
lot of the this nonsense they're the
ones that are literally just the
Democrats of 10 years ago let's be
honest here they're implementing the
same policies and if there ever is a
political party that hasn't been working
for the American people that actually
screwed them over and and gave them
failed promises you're right it's the
Republican Party